unless you get that first suggestion and
more more freestyle what do you want to
write about
i beg your pardon you said you said
you said pedophiles
yeah thank you correct are you paying
attention is that really what you want
to write about yeah
you're going to put me under the gun
what a horrible horrible saying
okay microscope
yeah microscope thank you
put me under the gun or a microscope
that's i think we've made the greatest
scientific discovery of our generation
oh dear
i've destroyed the sample okay
so pedophiles in the phrase under the
gun from that man there um
welcome back you're just in time to tell
me what you would like to hear a rap
about
oh [ __ ] yes exactly
anything at all
yeah
french fries cool okay
he said pedophiles under the gun
french fries
people in this kind of shrouded enclave
here what would you like a wreck about
chocolate chips
you're not in that shrouded enclave
but but again i feel like you've really
you had us in the gutter and then we
required two women to just be like
french fries and chocolate chips
ignore him
we're not all like him
thank you person not in the shrouded
enclave let's come to the the very back
of the room people on the back i want to
get you guys involved did you are you
raising a hand to your mouth you're
ready to bellow you're like oh yes go
for it
you you'd like [ __ ]
cool
what what what about it let's let's
expand let's be more specific
that's all you have well that's okay
that if you had more than that you'd be
a hermaphrodite which is fine
okay and to keep up with the trend
welcome back what would you like to hear
a rap about
boombox boom boxes very very quick and i
feel you've finished off the trifecta of
alliterative suggestions because she
said french fries she said chocolate
chips you said boom boxes he said
pedophiles and that lady over there said
[ __ ] that's all i have
so really you and you make friends uh
you three well done this
those are your five suggestions i'm
going to say the they're going to be
they're going to be great we're going to
turn them into beautiful improvised
hip-hop freestyle made up on the spot i
know you didn't know what was really
happening but that's what's happening
now um i'm going to ask my lovely band
to
come up with something that we're going
to wrap up
[Music]
good lordy
oh this is great cool
um i'm excited i hope all of y'all are
excited as well are you excited
thank you
and there's really no need to clap
professional drummer over there
came back from the bathrooms imagine
you're surprised english man on the
stage french fries you had to pause
before you were like yeah i'll swallow
all the tension in my throat waddle to
mcdonald's i'm gonna get that or maybe
in and out or maybe sheck shack we can
have a real route people fighting
they're like i prefer from the burger
king more crunchy on the outside and
soft within i like to get it i really
want to spoil put it in there i get a
fresh oil never make it risky always
make it crispy if it's burnt doesn't go
down well with chris t it's my name i'm
not saying christ i've got a more sweet
tooth so the thing that i like off i go
i want cookies in my mouth want a
chocolate chip given by tall house
that's the brand that i prefer i got
them in the kitchen stuff them in there
oh switching up the baseline on the beat
chocolate chip cookies my favorite treat
but if i want to mix it up make it more
frozen i'm like sup ben and jerry i
spoken to your manager would you do me a
favor it's like yo i'll send you a brand
new flavor cookie dough with the double
chocolate want it in my little fridge
here i got a lot of it i start
swallowing it i'm like eating it locked
within my chops then i pump out like a
boombox bb you can see me on the street
maybe on the metro other people eat
they'd be like oh [ __ ] they're coming
and they're playing all of the music on
the subway display and i don't want to
hear your tunes it feels so odd it
doesn't move my bard i got the airpods
pro so they cancelling the noise that
the boombox produces i don't like the
trash music that they're giving now i'm
like no i don't need them why they
always playing [ __ ] like ed sheeran or
other things from the country that i'm
from where we say pedophile get it
properly mon i don't want pedophile we
pronounce the a if you were being bad
man back in the day let me say we can
leave it out i won't believe most
popular pedophiles catholic priests all
of them they used to have such fun i
want to put them under the gun while i
don't really believe in punishment as
capital but let me talk about the little
phrase i'm trying to wrap it all up oh i
really hope you'll change your
linguistics for a microscope under the
microscope like a close inspection i see
a little [ __ ] i get an erection when i
say little i just mean in the size not
underage yes i provide oh don't get
fussy don't show the shyness you can say
[ __ ] fufu or vagina any of the words
they're totally valid if you want to say
what you've got yeah just tell it you're
like yeah my [ __ ] oh so hot what oh no
it's all i've got it's just right down
there it's a real hit you should see
nice bulbar on the sides of the slit oh
freestyle wrap that's what you get i
hope it leaves your vagina appropriately
wet
[Applause]